Одного ранку із звичайним вчителем трапилася несподівана історія.
доброго дня! Василь Петрович Голобородько?
Так, це я.
Доброго ранку, пане, Президенте!
На президентських виборах вигаданий сюжет може стати дійсністю.
Актор Володимир Зеленський є наразі лідером у рейтингах.
При цьому він веде досить своєрідну виборчу кампанію.
Жодних прямих контактів у натовпі людей,
майже жодних інтервю, жодних появ на публіці.
Все - лише на сцені.
Однак його обіцянка залишатися людиною досягає своєї мети.
Привіт всім! Я Володимир Зеленський.
я наважився ступити на територію наших еліт
і висунути свою кандидатуру на посаду Президента.
Тому вони оголосили мене клоуном.
Так, я клоун, і дуже цим пишаюся. І певен - не один я.
Але ким є насправді Зеленський?
У цьому будинку, де ніщо не говорить про ще, що відбувається всередині,
нині розташований його центральний виборчий штаб.
Тут працює багато молодих українців.
Атмосфера підкреслено відкрита і сучасна, майже як у стартап-компанії.
Досі Анжеліка Ульянова опікувалася стартапами.
А нині веде передвиборчу платформу Зеленського в Інстаграмі. Безшкоштовно.
Вона, як і багато представників її покоління,
цілковито покладається на актора-президента.
Ми всі його давно знаємо. Він знаменитість.
Ніхто ніколи не чув чогось поганого про нього як про людину.
Те, що у нього немає політичного досвіду, мало контактів у політиці -
Анжеліку не турбує. Навпаки
Та все його життя пов’язане з політикою.
Хоча й через гумор. Він у дотепній формі розповідає
про те, що коїться у нашій країні.
Але чи і справді Зеленським, улюбленим у народі актором розважального жанру,
рухає бажання заявити про себе на політичній сцені України?
У цьому сумніваються його опоненти.
Вони звинувачують його у тому,
що він є маріонеткою олігарха Ігоря Коломойського - суперника Президента Порошенка.
Адже саме його телеканал транслював майже всі серії про Зеленського.
Я не вважаю його маріонеткою.
Багато людей, які знають його особисто і бачили його в роботі,
кажуть, що у нього тверда воля і жорсткий лідерський стиль.
Він спробує дистанціюватися від Коломойського.
Він інтуїтивно розуміє, що це ризиковано.
А от чи в стані він самотужки змінити
вражені корупцією державні структури в Україні, експерт сумнівається.
Зеленський і його серіал породили досить популярні політичні ілюзії,
а саме віру в те, що лише аутсайдер з народу може впоратися з існуючою системою.
Це хибна думка. Самому з невеликою командою йому з цим не впоратися.
Однак Зеленський вселяє цю віру у таких молодих українців як Анжеліка.
Через 5 років після протестів тут на Майдані
представники її покоління  відчувають себе ошуканими українськими політиками.
Реформи пробуксовують.
На кожних виборах ми бачимо, як усе повторюється учергове.
Більш-менш оновлюються плакати і гасла
і навіть обіцянки залишаються тими ж.
Найважливіше у Володимирі - те, що він не обіцяє нам золоті гори.
У нього є бачення і бажання, він не дає обіцянок.
5 років тому Анжеліка перебралася до Києва зі Сходу країни.
Там усе ще панує війна.
Там, звідки я приїхала, усе ще стріляють.
Коли навідалася туди у новорічну ніч не могла заснути через обстріли.
У Києві всі забули про війну.
Анжеліка показує світлини свого сина.
Доки вона зайнята передвиборчою кампанією,
7- річний хлопчик живе з дідусем і бабусею в кількох кілометрах від фронту.
Я за Володимира Зеленського ще й тому, що він прагне об’єднати країну
і покласти край розколу між українсько і російськомовними громадянами.
У своєму серіалі "Слуга народу" та у передвиборчій кампанії однойменної партії
Зеленський крокує своїм шляхом до влади в Україні.
Тут вигадка та дійсність співпадають.
Дуже цікаво чи вдасться йому досягнути вступу на посаду Президента
у режимі реального часу.